pour le peuple québécois le dépôt de ce
projet de loi de ce projet de politique
linguistique marque que l'hiver vient de
desserrer son étreinte
camille laurens est celui par qui le
québec s'est donné les moyens de vivre
en français sa charte de la langue
française qu'on appelle la loi 101 est
adopté par l'assemblée nationale le 26
août 1977 elle impose l'usagé exclusif
du français dans l'affichage public et
la publicité et des programmes de
francisation pour les entreprises de 50
employés plus elle resterait aussi
l'accès à l'école anglophone aux seuls
enfants dont un des parents a été éduqué
en anglais au québec et fait du français
la langue officielle des lois et du
système de justice
il est évident que la vitalité
culturelle et linguistique doit
constituer une priorité absolue une
priorité dans l'élément central qui est
à la fois l'âme et le ciment c'est
toujours la langue
les avancées sont rapides le français
prend plus de place dans les commerces
les services et les directions
d'entreprise et le pourcentage d'enfants
immigrants qui vont à l'école
francophone triple en neuf ans seulement
mais la tension est grande avec les
anglophones qui quittent le québec par
milliers pendant le premier mandat du
parti québécois rrq accueille depuis le
sentier comme québécois qui veut partir
qu'ils s'en aillent
et les contestations juridiques sont
chaîne et avec les années la loi 101
père du mordant québec doit sans cesse
s'ajuster aux jugements des tribunaux la
charte québécoise ne fait pas partie de
la constitution du canadien en 1979 la
cour suprême déclarant
inconstitutionnels l'exclusivité du
français comme langue législatives et
juridiques
puis quelques années plus tard c'est au
tour de l'accès restreint aux écoles
anglophones d'être invalidée québec fait
un compromis et permet cet accès à tous
ceux dont l'un des parents à étudier en
anglais où que ce soit au canada au nom
de la liberté d'expression c'est ensuite
au tour de l' usage unique du français
dans l'affichage d'être déclarée
inconstitutionnelle en 1988
le sujet est sensible des milliers de
québécois manifestent pour protéger
leurs lois sans robert bourassa finira
par proposer un autre compromis
l'affichage bilingue possible mais avec
la prédominance du français avec des
mots superbe
en 2002 c'est le 25e anniversaire de la
loi 100 globalement le bilan est bon
mais une nouvelle inquiétude apparaît le
français au travail décline surtout à
montréal
ce projet doit être suffisamment fort
pour changer la trajectoire de retour au
pouvoir en 2012 le parti québécois
propose d'imposer de nouvelles règles
aux pme de revoir le statut bilingue des
municipalités et les conditions
d'admission au cégep anglophone mais
l'opposition dont fait partie la caq de
françois legault s'y opposent
le gouvernement de pauline marois
minoritaires abandonne son projet de
réforme
huit ans plus tard la place du français
continue de décliner dans plusieurs
milieux une enquête démontre entre
autres que 63% des entreprises
montréalaises demande la connaissance de
l'anglais al embauche
cette loi ça va être le geste plus fort
qui aurait été posée depuis le dépôt de
la loi 101 en 1960 la cad à son tour y
va de son projet de réforme au moment où
tous les partis s'entendent sur
l'importance de renforcer la loi ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
moria